NICK BUTCHER: Hello, good
morning, everyone, and welcome.
Thank you for
coming to our talk.
Today we're going to talk
about two very highly requested
user features which
are new in Android Q,
and that is dark theme
and gesture navigation.
My name is Nick Butcher, I'm
an engineer on the Android
Developer Relations Team.
CHRIS BANES: My name
is Chris Baines,
and I'm also an engineer on
the Android Developer Relations
Team.
ROHAN SHAH: And I'm Rohan.
I'm a PM on the Android
System UI and Launcher Team.
NICK BUTCHER: We got a lot to
go today, so let's get started.
First up, we want to talk
about the dark theme.
Wait, that's better, dark theme.
So why is dark theme important?
We think there's
three major reasons.
The first up is supporting
using your applications
in darker environments.
How often have you used your
phone in a darkened room
and been blinded by a
bright white screen, which
is not what you want?
Supporting a dark theme enables
usage of your app in many wider
situations.
Secondly, by lighting up
less pixels on the screen,
we've seen significant
reductions in power usage.
In fact, in our
tests we've seen up
to 60% reduction
in power usage when
the app is in the
foreground, which
can be a real user benefit.
And lastly, dark themes
can support accessibility
while maintaining
sufficient contrast ratios.
They have less eye
strain on the user
so that could be used by
certain classes of user
much more comfortably.
So for those reasons, we've
introduced a new system
setting in Android Q.
So now under the devices
display settings,
you can choose between
a light or a dark theme.
You can also use a new
Quick Settings toggle
to quickly flip
between those modes
and the device
will automatically
kick into dark theme when your
device enters Battery Saver.
Now it's important to note the
dark theme is actually a system
wide setting, not
just to the system UI,
but it applies to all apps
running on the device.
And as such we
think that users are
going to increasingly expect
your applications that you're
writing to respond when
they set this system toggle.
So here for example I've got two
apps running in split screen,
and when I toggle
into a dark theme,
we can see that only
one of them responds.
And we think the users are
going to increasingly expect
your application to follow this.
Now I've picked on Google
Drive here because they're not
currently supporting theme,
but all Google applications
are actually committed
to update to support
dark theme by the time
Android Q rolls out.
So this is only going to
increase the user expectations.
So as such, we
strongly recommend
that you look at supporting
dark theme in your applications.
Now we recognize that's
going to be some work for you
developers, us developers,
and so as such,
we're introducing something
new in Android Q which
is a feature called Force Dark.
Now Force Dark attempts
to automatically apply
a dark theme to a light
theme application.
Well, let's take a look.
So here's the Google
I/O application
and here it is with Force
Dark being applied to it.
And it does so in a
kind of intelligent way.
It runs at rendering time and
actually inspects the views
that it's rendering and
tries to smartly work out
which ones should be inverted
in order to run dark.
It even does some clever stuff
like looking bitmap drawables
and tries to work out if
there's a variation in the hue,
is this some kind
of photographic data
and not invert certain
kind of images.
So it's got some smart
heuristics in it.
Force Dark is opt in,
you have to turn it
on for your application.
And you do so like
this, by setting
Force Dark allowed to true.
Here I'm setting it at the theme
level for my entire application
theme so it will apply
everywhere throughout the app.
But you can choose
where to turn it
on so you could turn on just
for one or two activities
and use it almost as
a kind of migration
to help you rapidly
adopt a dark theme.
So Force Dark can help you
to rapidly adopt dark theme,
but we still actually
recommend that you
look into designing a custom
dark theme, which you can do so
using themes and styles.
The reason for
this, well, there's
two main reasons this really.
The first one is that Force Dark
is only available on Android Q,
so it's only going to
benefit users on Q forward.
Whereas implementing
a custom dark theme
is actually using the standard
Android styling techniques.
You can roll out your dark
theme into all kind of major API
levels.
The second reason why
we think it's important
go custom is it gives you
utmost control over exactly
how your app renders, which
is what you want, right?
You don't actually
get to hook into how
Force Dark will darken
your applications
or how it will
change the colors.
So if you want control
over, if your designers
wants to be able to control
the exact shades of blue
that they're [INAUDIBLE]
here is going to change to,
for example, then a custom
theme is the way to go.
So to help you to
design for dark themes,
we've just released this
week some updated guidance
on the material.io
website, which
covers how to generally design
a dark themed application.
With specific guidance
around important areas
such as accessibility
and guidance on how
to adapt your apps color system
to work under a dark palette.
In fact, there's another
session at Google I/O right
after this one on
stage one which
is all about how to
design for the dark theme.
So to implement a dark
theme, we recommend
that you take a look at the
AppCompat material design
components libraries which Chris
is going to talk about now.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks
Nick, so DayNight
is a feature in
AppCompact which we've
had for a number
of years now, which
allows you to easily
implement one of those custom
themes in your app.
Now the way it works is by
enabling the Night Resource
Qualifier, and it works back
to API 14, which Android 4.0.
We've been hard at work for
the past couple of months
to improve it and that is
available in AppCompact
1.1, which is available now.
To implement a theme
using DayNight,
the first thing you need to
do is change your theme parent
to be one of the themes that
are compatible with DayNight
variance.
If you're using
materials on components,
which I'd recommend
you do, it also
provides a DayNight theme in its
version 1.1, again, available
now.
As we mentioned
earlier, AppCompat
enables the -night
resource qualifier to work.
And that is exactly how
the theme is implemented.
You can see in our
default configuration
that DayNight points to
Theme.AppCompat.Light, which
means that when the
light theme is selected,
we'll use a light theme.
And when in our
night configuration,
in values-night, it points to
a Theme.AppCompat, which means
we'll go dark.
The next thing we
need to do is tell
AppCompat what mode to use.
Now we have two APIs for that.
The first is
setDefaultNightMode,
which is used when
you want to set
a mode across your entire app,
so all of your activities.
If you need a local override
in a specific activity,
we have setLocalNightMode.
Now one thing to note
is that the values
you set on these APIs
are not persisted.
So therefore, you need to set--
use the method whenever your
app process is brought up.
Usually you'll do in
you application object.
Using those APIs, you
need to give it a mode.
And we offer four main modes.
The first is MODE_NIGHT_YES,
which means always dark.
MODE_NIGHT_NO, which
is always light.
FOLLOW_SYSTEM, which will follow
the current system setting.
Now on Q because we have a new
system setting, which is great,
it will do that basically.
Whenever the system
setting is changed,
your app will follow it.
When your running on devices
before Q, so Pie or earlier,
it will usually default
to a white theme.
The next new mode is
called AUTO_BATTERY, which
we've added in AppCompat 1.1.
And that goes dark whenever
battery saver feature
is enabled.
And it works back to API 21.
So you can see an
example where a device is
going into battery saving mode.
When that happens, your app
will automatically go dark.
When the user plugs
the device back in,
it goes back to charging,
and therefore we
leave battery saver
mode, like so.
We'll automatically
go light again.
The final thing to
check is to make sure
that your activities
are extended
from AppCompat activity.
This may sound super
obvious, but its something
which is easily forgotten.
So as I said earlier,
we've been hard at work
over the past couple of
months to improve the DayNight
feature.
And so I'd like to take through
some of the things we've done.
So one key change is that
setDefaultNightMode now
recreates any
visible activities.
It previously didn't
do this and you
had to do all that
work yourself,
whereas we now do it for you.
We also have an
incompatibility with WebView.
Whereas if you're using
DayNight and then later
inflated WebView,
we'd reset the theme
and then things
would go very wrong.
And that's now fixed.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
The final thing is that
MODE_NIGHT_AUTO_TIME is now
that deprecated.
As I said earlier,
we've been hard at work
over fixing many, many bug
fixes, which you've all raised.
So hopefully, if you've had
any issues, they're fixed.
That leads into an
app theme setting.
So to support user
customization,
we recommend providing
a way for users
to choose the theme that
they want in your app.
An example could be
an e-book reader.
If a user knows
that they are always
going to use the app at
night, and they always
want it to be dark,
you want to find a way
for the user to select that.
We recommend there
be three options
when we're [INAUDIBLE]
Android Q. Light, dark,
and then system default. System
default being the default
option for your app.
If you're running
it on Android P
or before, because we don't
have that system setting,
the options are
slightly different.
They're now light, dark,
and set by battery saver.
Now the keen-eyed
among you will notice
that those options
map pre-directly
to some of the AppCompat modes
and that's totally on purpose.
There's a 1-to-1 correlation
between those options
and the modes we actually
have and we offer you.
So now I'm going to
hand it over to Nick
to talk about how elevation
works with dark theme.
NICK BUTCHER: Elevation.
So in material design,
elevation is a key concept
for showing the
importance of some content
in your application, by changing
the elevation of the surface
and for hinting at
interaction cues.
Now in light themes, this is
represented with a shadow.
And as the elevation
raises up, the shadow
becomes more diffuse.
But when you have a dark
background, like in dark theme,
this can be harder to see.
And as such, we're introducing
the idea of elevation overlays.
The idea here being that,
as the surface raises up
to get closer to the
virtual light source,
the actual surface
color itself changes,
as if there was a
semi-opaque white layer
on top of it, which gets
more opaque as you raise up
in elevation.
Don't worry.
We're not actually
doing overdraw
of the white layer on top.
This is actually, we kind
of blend down the color
and use it as a tint on
the background color.
So to use elevation
overlays, then
all of the components in
material design components
version 1.1 onwards will
support this out the box.
These are the
components which use
the color surface attribute
for the background color
and support elevation.
And as such, just by setting
the elevation on the components,
you'll get this surface
overlay behavior.
But if you want to build this
behavior into your own custom
components, there's
a couple of options.
Firstly, you could use
the MaterialShapeDrawable,
which is the kind of
background drawable
which powers a lot of materials.
Shape theming, as well as this
material elevation overlays.
And you can use these in
your overviews as well.
It's been augmented
with new API,
such as
createWithElevationOverlay or
setElevation or setTranslationZ,
which will give you
this overlay behavior.
If you can't use the
MaterialShapeDrawable
for some reason, you
can instead take a look
at the
ElevationOverlayProvider class,
which is what
MaterialShapeDrawable
uses under the hood.
This gives you
lower level methods,
such as working out the
surface color for a given
elevation, which you can then
use in custom drawing the same.
Now, implementing dark
themes, as we said,
comes down a lot to good hygiene
with your applications, themes,
and styles.
And we've given you some
specific tips and gotchas
when implementing dark modes.
Quite commonly,
we've seen an issue
where applications,
which are designed
like this for a
light screen, where
they might have dark text
on the light background.
When they apply a
dark theme to the app,
you see an issue like this,
where you end up with, say,
dark text on a dark
background, which you end up
not being able to read.
Or perhaps the text
correctly inverts to light,
but your background
remains light.
So these are common issues
that we see in applications
supporting dark theme.
And generally when
this happens is
you've made some assumption
that somewhere in your layouts
about being running
under a light theme.
And you've kind of
hardcoded some colors,
like hardcoded a white
background or black text
in this case.
Now you're probably
not hardcoding things
like this in your layout,
but you're probably using
some kind of color resource.
And this is
essentially the same.
If you only provide color value
in the default configuration,
this is essentially
the same, that it's not
going to respond when
running under dark theme.
What you need to do is
provide an alternative color
when running under the
night configuration
here in the values-night folder.
And as such, these
colors will then
respond to the theme change.
Better yet, you can take a
look at using theme attributes.
Theme attributes are
essentially semantically named
colors, which have different
values when running
under a light or a dark theme.
So here for example,
I'm changing
that hardcoded background
from white to materials color
surface color, which is a
kind of background color.
And so that will flip from
white in a light theme
to a very dark gray when
running under dark theme.
Or likewise, I'm using the
platforms text color primary
here for the text color,
which will give you
the inverse of that.
So it will be dark
in a light theme
and light in the dark theme.
In fact, if you take a look
at the material color system,
it has lots of these
semantically named colors,
which are super useful
for using in your designs.
So you're probably
familiar with things
like color primary, color
secondary, color accents,
and so on.
But here's the surface color
that we looked at before.
But they also provide a
series of on colors, so colors
which will contrast on
top of the relevant color.
So On Primary, On
Secondary, On Surface.
So for example, the
On Surface color
is a color which
will always contrast
on top of that
background Surface color.
So we can use this
in combination
with a neat trick that
colors state list provides
to great effect
during dark theme.
So for example here,
I am using the fact
that color state list
lets you separate out
the color from the alpha channel
and define them separately.
So I'm grabbing the
colorOnSurface, so
something that will always
contrast the surface color,
and applying an alpha
modification to it.
So this can be
super useful if you
want avoid having 50 different
shades of gray in your colors
XML file that you are
scared to kind of update,
because you don't know
where they're going to use.
Instead of that, if you can
reference these colors always
guaranteed to be the
right color to contrast,
given a different theme.
And just apply an
alpha modification.
It can be super useful.
One caveat is this alpha
kind of modification
was introduced in
API 23, Marshmallow.
So if you want to
use it beforehand,
make sure you're using the
AppCompat resources path,
or loading it like this in code.
Similarly, whenever you're
loading colors in code using
context compact,
.getColor, for example,
be wary that you want to ensure
that those colors as well have
night configurations.
Or better yet, you might
want to do something
like this code here, which
is querying the current theme
for a theme attribute.
So this is how
you can get access
to something like text
color primary or color
surface in your code.
Another class of issues we've
seen is around drawables.
So if you have
drawables, you probably
want them to be showing up,
like these light drawables here,
but you might encounter
similar issues,
as we saw before, where you
might end up with dark-on-dark.
Or you could look at providing
completely separate versions
of the drawables under the
drawable-night configurations.
A better way is
actually probably
to look at tinting,
because usually these
are monochrome icons that
you just want them to change
the entire color of them.
So you can tint at
a couple of levels.
You can either tint at
the view level here.
So here I am going
to tint whatever
drawables giving me with
whatever colorSecondary
is for the current theme.
So it'll update it
depending on the theme.
Or hopefully you're
using vector drawables
throughout your
app assets, which
natively support tinting on
the root element of the vector.
So here I'm setting the
colorControlNormal theme
attribute, which is the standard
kind of gray icon color.
So setting this means
your icons will always
be the exactly right color.
Or if you're
working in code, you
could also use the
DrawableCompat class,
which can apply a tint
dynamically to a drawable
as well.
And lastly, it can be handy to
work out if you're currently
running under a
dark theme, which
you can do with some code like
this, which actually looks
at the configuration's
UI mode and checks
whether this is
currently in night mode.
So this is useful for querying
whether you're under night mode
and maybe branching your logic
or setting a different tint
on a drawable or some such.
Those were just quick tips about
working with themes and styles.
We could spend the whole
talk talking about--
well, you could-- talking
about themes and styles.
But we've actually already
done that a couple of times.
So I highly recommend
you check out
these with resources on that.
Lastly, I want to
revisit Force Dark
and talk about how it can help
you to migrate to a dark theme.
So here's an
application designed
for a light presentation.
And when we apply
Force Dark to it,
we can see it's generally
done a pretty good job of it.
It's is generally inverted
a lot of the colors.
There's a few opportunities.
It could be better
in my opinion.
In fact, if we compare it to
a custom dark theme, which
I designed, you can see a few
things which force dark hasn't
done quite right.
For example, if we zoom
in on this drawable
on the left, which is
indicating the depth
of a threaded conversation,
Force Dark has made it a bit
too light for my tastes.
What you can do in
these situations, is
you can set the
forceDarkAllowed to false
on any given view or view
group and disable the Force
Dark behavior just for
that part of the hierarchy.
But remember, when you
set Force Dark to false,
the general
configuration is still
running under the night mode.
And as such, we can use
things like tinting.
And this tint
color will give you
the right color for a
theme, so this will respond
to the night configuration.
So check out Force Dark.
Like I said, it's one
line change in your theme
to set it for your application.
Or we've actually introduced
a new developer option
where you can force the
entire device into this Force
Dark mode.
So if you want to
check it out now,
if you're running
Beta 3 or newer,
you can see how your app
responds to Force Dark.
So next up, Chris going to
introduce some common scenarios
we're seeing with dark mode.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks, Nick.
So the first thing we're
going to to talk about
is web content.
Now the good news is that
WebView works seamlessly
with Force Dark.
So if you're opted
into Force Dark
when you're running under Q
and you have an example here.
So we have an app
here, which you load
into Google.com in a WebView.
And we've enabled
Force Dark on this app.
And when we go into night mode,
it changes the WebView as well.
It also works in Chrome,
Chromium-based browsers,
and WebView.
So soon actual web
content will be
able to support dark theme
natively, using their
the CSS media query called
prefers-color-scheme.
We've also added dark theme
support in custom browser tabs.
And by that, we mean
the UI around it.
So we have a new
method on Custom Tabs
intent called setColorScheme.
It takes one of
these three options.
Now when-- here, we're in light
theme, but when we go to dark,
it looks a little bit like this.
Now you'll notice that
the content itself
doesn't have Force Dark
applied or anything like that.
That's because we're
aligned on the web
content itself to use that
media query we just spoke about.
Now MapView itself doesn't
support dark theme out
of the box, but
we can easily make
it do so by using its custom
map styling functionality.
Now custom map
styling allows you
to specify the colors
and text and stuff
of a map via JSON file.
You can see a link to a
website we can actually
download some map styles
that we provide for you.
I think there's nine
styles on there.
Some are light, some are
dark, but you can also
customize it to your needs.
Now, we can actually
use that feature
by using the -night
resource qualifier
that we spoke about earlier
to make MapView sport dark
theme natively.
So in our default
configuration, we'll
put a light-styled map in
the JSON file in res/raw.
And then in res/raw-night, we'll
put a dark-styled JSON file.
And that way MapView
will automatically
load the correct map style and
then use the correct colors.
NICK BUTCHER: Another issue we
see when adopting dark themes
is with illustrations,
which you're probably
using in empty states or
maybe onboarding or closing
your applications.
If you just use the
same illustration
design for light theme
under a dark theme,
you can see too
high contrast, where
these colors are,
like, way too saturated
and they contrast very highly
on these darkened backgrounds.
We recommend that you
provide an alternate version
when running under
a dark theme, which
is more harmonious with
the darker backgrounds.
Now again, you could just
provide an alternate version
of this drawable, so
you have two versions
of very similar drawables
in your application,
but a better way
to do this might
be to use an effective
drawables ability to reference
color resources.
The individual fills
or strokes of paths.
And as such, you can vary
just the colors, when running
under a night configuration.
So this way, you
only have to ship
one version of the
drawable, but have
the colors respond to when it's
running under a dark theme.
Next up is notifications.
So notifications, when
running under a dark theme,
will respond and go dark.
So if you're using any of
the notification templates,
these will work
just out of the box.
But if you're using
a custom layout,
you're setting a custom
layout, than all the rules
we talked about before
about sliding still apply.
So don't assume it's
running under a light mode.
Don't hardcode colors.
Use theme attributes.
In fact, I'd encourage
you, if you're
sliding any text in
particular, to look
at the subclasses of the
notification text appearance,
so that your text will
mirror that of the system's
notifications as well.
So that was dark mode.
Our take aways
really are that users
are going to increasingly
expect your applications
to support dark theme,
so really, really
do take a look at
supporting it as well.
Use AppCompat, DayNight, and
material design components,
which have lots of
built-in support
for implementing this
in your applications.
And be sure to look for these
latest versions, these 1.1.0,
because there's been lots of
improvements and bug fixes
in them.
Consider Force Dark as
something to help you rapidly
adopt a dark theme.
And maybe use it as
a migration tool,
so you can enable it
for certain activities
and then roll out
custom themes gradually.
And theme attribute
all the things.
Don't think about
being hardcoded
in a single configuration,
a single color scheme.
Be very flexible.
Whenever you see a
hardcoded color or color
resource, if only
a single version,
see that as a red flag.
So now I'm going to
head over to Rohan,
who's going to tell us
all about gesture nav.
Cheers.
ROHAN SHAH: All right, so I
have the benefit of telling you
all about gesture nav.
A few of you might have played
with it already on Beta 3.
If you haven't, make
sure you give it a go.
It's out there in settings.
You can search for fully
gestural navigation.
But I'll do a quick
refresher of what it looks
like right now in Android Q.
So we're adding a new nav mode,
if you haven't already heard,
in Android Q that replaces
the beloved three buttons
with three glorious gestures.
And here's what they look like.
On the left, you can see
that swipe up from the bottom
will become the
gesture for home.
Swiping up and
holding in the middle
will take you to your
recent and/or overview.
And on the left, you can see
that swiping in from an edge
will take you back.
Now the one thing that this
movie doesn't really do justice
is that we're also introducing
swiping left and swiping
right in order to go back.
We think it's a super
awesome experience.
Internally, we love it.
We've heard really
great feedback.
We definitely want to hear
how you feel about it.
But definitely give it a try.
So a big question
we've gotten is,
we're introducing another nav
mode in Android, what do we do?
Like, we're developers, what
are you trying to do in Android?
So I want to talk about that
a little bit really quickly.
In the future for
Android, we're going
to be supporting two nav
modes moving forward.
The first one is three buttons.
You know, Android users
love three buttons.
We know that it's super usable.
And it also addresses a lot
of accessibility needs that
gestures just cannot.
On other hand, we also
know that there is
a lot of desire for gestures.
So we will be
supporting one gesture
mode, which is what you saw,
moving forward in Android.
And only that one.
I want to take a quick
step back and talk
about why we're doing this now,
before we dive into the details
for developers.
And talk about user trends here.
So Dan Sandler talked
about this in his talk
in what's new on Android.
But users increasingly
want immersive experiences
in Android.
And one thing that
device makers have done
is try to approach this
from a software side.
And what they've done is
built their own gesture nav.
And every device maker
has a different impression
of how gesture nav should work.
What we recognize,
on the platform side,
is that kind of gets
insane for a developer,
thinking about n different
gesture navs when
you're trying to develop.
Just design for, test for your
app, just kind of gets insane.
So with that in mind, we
introduced this gesture nav
in Q. And we're going
to be standardizing
the ecosystem as of Q on
three buttons and our model
moving forward.
And just want to elaborate
the problem here.
You know, there's a lot
of different gestures.
These are just some of them.
Dan's talk had
different swirl gestures
and maybe a knock knock
does something different,
but we do want to unify
that core set of gestures,
back, home, and recents.
Taking a slightly
different spin on this,
why should you care as an app?
I'm going to regurgitate
that immersion bit,
but flipping this
a little bit, there
is an opportunity
for you, as an app,
to delight your user by bringing
this immersive experience
to your app.
And making sure that it's
compatible with this new nav
mode.
In terms of compatibility,
we recognize
that there may be some
conflicts that you
will need to handle as an app.
And we'll talk about
that coming up.
Cool.
So how do you make
your app nav-ready?
And nav just means, you
know, any nav mode, 3 button,
gesture nav.
How do you prepare for
this immersive experience?
And more importantly, how do
you prepare for gesture nav?
There are three
things you need to do.
The first one is making
sure that your app
goes edge-to-edge, which Chris
will explain a little bit more.
The second thing you need to do
is leverage insets, old insets
and new ones that we're
adding, to make sure
that any kind of critical
content is in a safe place
and is in optimal positioning.
And the third and final
thing is handling conflicts.
If you do have a conflict,
how do you handle it,
and how can you override
certain gestures
so you can bring a better
delightful experience
to your app?
Cool.
So I'll hand it over to Chris
to talk about edge-to-edge.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks, Rohan.
Yeah, so what is
actually edge-to-edge?
Well let's take a look
at a typical app when
you're running Android Q today.
So here you can see
the bounds of the app
are actually below
the status bar
and above the navigation bar.
So what do you want on Q?
Well simply, we want
the navigation bar
to disappear, allowing
your apps content
to be displayed
behind it, to create
a more immersive experience.
When it scrolls, it
looks a bit like this.
So as recommendation, drawing
behind the navigation bar
is now strongly recommended
on Q. It's optional before Q,
but one thing to note is
that a lot of the APIs
and how you do this
actually works back
to previous versions of Android.
So if you're going to
put the work in for Q,
it's not that much more work
to do it for previous to Q,
as well.
Now let's take a look
at the status bar.
Now similarly, we actually
want the status bar
to go away as well.
Again, allowing your app content
to be displayed behind it,
creating a more
immersive experience.
And you'll hear the
word immersive a lot
in this presentation.
So now our app looks a little
bit like this when it scrolls.
Again, drawing behind the status
bar is now recommended on Q,
and optional before Q. So if
we take a look at our bounds,
they've come from
here to here, which is
where we get edge-to-edge from.
So let's take a look at
now about how much actually
implement this stuff.
So the good news is that
from Android Q onwards,
the system is now responsible
for recoloring the system
buttons and the handles.
So you can see here, an
example, where as we scroll,
that navigation bar
handle at the bottom
is changing color based
on the content behind it.
Now the recoloring
can take the form
of both dynamic color adaption,
which you've just seen.
Or it could be static coloring
on less powerful devices.
When you're running
on older platforms,
because that recurring
doesn't happen,
we recommend that you set a
translucent nav bar color,
so the user can actually
see those buttons.
So to really make
your app go immersive,
there are three
things you need to do.
The first is change
your system bar colors.
Second, request to be
laid out fullscreen.
And then the final thing
is to avoid any overlaps
with your views
with the system UI.
So let's go for it.
The first one is the change
in the navigation bar color.
Now, we have this attribute
available in Lollipop onwards,
which we can use.
And we're just going to
set it to transparent.
When you run on
Pie or before you
should use a translucent
color as we just mentioned.
The next thing we
need to do is request
to be laid out fullscreen.
Now we're going to use the
infamous set systemUiVisibility
method, with a number of flags.
The two flags we need
are FLAG_LAYOUT_HIDE,
and that tells the system to
lay as out as if the navigation
bar wasn't there.
And a second is
LAYOUT_STABLE, which
is special flag that
tells it to lay us out
at it at our most extreme.
If you also want to be
displayed behind the status bar,
there's an additional
flag you need to use
called LAYOUT_FULLSCREEN.
Now when we lay
out fullscreen, we
don't want our views to be
displayed behind the system
bars.
And that is where
insets come into play.
Now insets are a collection
of values which tell you
how much to move or
inset content by.
Now what views you move,
how much you move it by,
depends on the inset
and its purpose.
And you might have seen
the in WindowInsets class.
There are a number
of types of insets.
The first type are called
system window insets
and they tell you
where the system UI is
being displayed over your app.
They are commonly used to move
views that are not obscured
by any of the system bars.
So here you can see a
FAB at the bottom right.
So we blow that up a little bit.
Typically a FAB will have a
16 dip margin applied to it.
And you can see that they are
denoted by these blue bars.
So actually, in gesture
nav, it's not too bad.
It's only obscured by
the bottom 2 dips or so.
So we'll use the system window
inset to actually move that up.
But in free button
navigation mode,
it's actually a lot worse,
because the navigation
bar is taller, our FAB
is a lot more obscured.
So by using the
system insets, we
can move out and make sure the
user can actually click it.
So as a recap,
system window insets
are used to move
clickable views.
The next type are called
system gesturing insets.
And they're new in
Q. Now they represent
the areas of the window where
system gestures take priority.
Visually, they look
a bit like this.
So let's go through them.
They include the vertical
edges for the back gesture.
So if the user starts
dragging from an anywhere
in the left and the
right hand zones,
the back gesture will
start triggering.
And again, on the bottom
side, where the home gesture
takes place, again if the
user start dragging there,
the home gesture will
take will take priority.
Now as mentioned,
system window insets
we use for clickable views,
system gesturing insets
are used for draggable views.
We'll go for
example a bit later.
The next and final type
are called mandatory system
gesturing insets.
And they're a subset of system
gesture insets which define
the areas which cannot be
used with exclusion APIs,
which Rohan will talk
about in a minute.
Now in Q, they are currently
only used for the home gesture,
because that's a
protected gesture
that users should always
be able to exit your app.
ROHAN SHAH: Right.
CHRIS BANES: Maybe
not over to Rohan.
So as a quick overview, system
window insets are clickable.
Gesturing insets are draggable.
And mandatory system
gesture insets
are used to check
the exclusion APIs.
Now actually over to Rohan.
ROHAN SHAH: There we go.
So the third and final thing
in making your app nav ready
is overwriting system gestures.
So Chris already
talked a little bit
about some of the system
gesture insets and ones
that are mandatory.
But I want to quickly talk
about what kinds of conflicts
you may have to handle.
And where you may
need to override.
So any sort of horizontally
draggable content
that resides in
those back zones,
within those system
gesture insets,
is an area where your
app may have conflict.
I want to give a
quick example here.
But I opened up a
photo in the Photos app
and I wanted to crop a
picture and crop my buddy out.
And you'll realize that the crop
handles, the little circles you
can see on each
corner of that square,
are awfully close to the edge.
And unfortunately, those are
in the system gesture insets
and in that back zone.
So there are other examples like
this, you know with sliders,
seek bars, video seek bars, for
example, other drag handles,
et cetera, that your app
may need to be aware of.
Great.
So how do you override
some of these gestures?
How do you make
sure that your user
is able to use those
crop handles, et cetera?
So there is a new
API available in Q
that will allow you to opt out
of, at least the back gesture.
Home is still a mandatory area.
We know that's the only way
a user can leave your app,
so we're not making
that opt-out-able.
But basically how
the API works is
that you can
specify a rectangles
on screen where basically
you'll get touch events,
instead of the system
consuming it for back,
or for any gesture in that area.
One quick word of caution.
This is pretty powerful.
One quick word of
caution here is
that, be really careful
when using this.
Users expect to be
able to go back.
It is one of the most
frequently used system actions.
I think it's used
twice as much as home.
And if you suddenly
break that and decide
to take over the entire
edge, for example,
your users might get frustrated.
So be really careful
when using this.
And make sure that you have
very clear visual affordances,
such as the drag handle, that
indicate that you can actually
swipe there.
And a user will start
interacting with app content
instead of going back.
Taking a quick look
at the API, it's
going to be in the View class.
And it's called
setSystemGestureExclusionRects.
And it takes in a
list of rectangles
where your app will get the
touch events first and only.
You can use this in onLayout, if
you have kind of static content
that isn't really shifting.
Or you can set this
in onDraw, if you
want more kind of real time
frame-by-frame updates.
Cool.
So let's talk about
some common scenarios
with all of these three
pieces of guidance.
And Chris will take over here.
CHRIS BANES: Right,
so the first scenario
we're going to look
through is scrolling views.
Now, as you can
see here, content
should be drawn behind
the navigation bar
as the list scrolls,
but when they user
reaches the end of that
list, that final item
should still be above
the navigation bar,
allowing the user
to interact with it.
As you can see here.
When we reach the
end of the list,
we still want those bottom
items, lightning talks,
in this instance, to still
be above the navigation bar,
so that users can interact.
So a common way to achieve
this would be through padding.
And we'll pad our scrolling view
using the system window insets
that we spoke about earlier.
Here's a quick code example.
We'll set an on apply
window insets listener,
and then we'll
waive some insets.
And then we'll just set the
pattern on the scrolling view,
in this it's the recycler view,
using the system window inset
pattern.
And the final thing
we need to do here
is something called
clip to padding.
Now by default,
whenever a view group
sets padding, or has
padding set on it,
it will clip its children.
Now that's because that's
the whole effect we want.
We want our children to be
displayed behind our pattern.
We need to turn
that feature off.
So recycler view, list view, and
all the other scrolling views
support this.
So just need to set to false.
The next scenario is all
about navigation drawers.
Now if you've tried
Beta 3, you'll
probably have noticed that a lot
of apps use navigation drawers
and it can sometimes
get a bit funky.
So DrawerLayout
will automatically
exclude the correct
edges as necessary.
So here you can see,
in the Google I/O App,
that when the drawer is
closed, it will open.
And the next gesture,
when it's open,
the back gesture will
actually take preference.
Now to use this, you need
updates on 1.1.0-alpha01,
which just released this week.
The bottom sheets,
generally, we want
to avoid views near the
vertically scrolling gesture
zones.
But bottom sheets are obviously
a pattern which a lot of apps
use.
So for collapsible
bottom sheets,
we want to make
sure there's enough
content above the
navigation bar for the user
to be able to actually drag it.
So here we're
looking at an example
where we haven't done that.
And you can see that as the user
tries to drag the bottom sheet,
actually the home gesture
is going to takeover.
And we don't want
that obviously.
So one way we get
around it is by using
the system gesture insets to
increase our content size,
allowing enough space for the
user to actually drag it as so.
Since there's a code, here we're
using the bottom sheet behavior
from material on components.
And it provides peekHeight.
So that's the amount of height
available when it's collapsed.
So here, again, we're using on
apply window insets listener,
we'll grab our system
gestures, and then
we'll just increase
that peek height.
Now it's also
available in ViewCompat
in the core library in AndroidX.
And again, we've released
a new version this week,
called 1.2.0-alpha01.
But remember, users
can always swipe
to go home by swiping at
the bottom of the screen.
So even though we've
done this and we've
moved the peek high up, users
can still accidentally trigger
this gesture.
And that's obviously
annoying for users.
So draggable content
near the gesture nav zone
is possible, but be careful
if you're going to do it.
One thing also to say
is to try and make
the draggable content
more obvious to the user,
so they drag the right bit.
So here you can see
that the actual header
bar is fully opaque,
the content below it
actually has an
alpha effect applied,
trying to guide the
user to the top section.
The next scenario is carousels.
What that would
mean, view pages,
or any horizontally scrolling
lists, like recycler views.
Now one thing we
don't really want
is for apps to set
exclusion rects everywhere,
because that's a
problem for users.
If an app sets exclusion rects
all across the left and right
zones, the user is not going
to know where they can actually
trigger back.
The final scenario is
what about landscape?
So if you've gone edge-to-edge,
what we talked about earlier,
in landscape, when in button
mode, what we'll actually get
is, which obviously isn't great.
So you can see that the
button options are actually
obscured by our apps content.
Now this doesn't
happen on gesture mode.
You only have this
on button mode.
So if you have content which
starts near a vertical edge,
think about padding all of
the content in horizontally.
And one thing to
note also is make
sure you test your apps both
on button modes and also
the gesture nav modes.
As a code example,
it's pretty easy.
You just need to find a
view somewhere [INAUDIBLE]
near the top, set an on
apply window insets listener,
and then set the left
and right padding based
on the system window insets.
And that's safe to use
in all our orientations,
because it will always
give you the right values.
And once you've done that,
you're looking a bit like this.
I just want to say, we
are adding more support
in our AndroidX libraries,
Jetpack libraries,
to make this a lot
easier for you.
The examples we've
just gone through
are just trying to show you
how we've tried to implement
this in our libraries.
But if you have custom
views, obviously you're
also going to need to
do something similar.
Now if there's difficult
patterns that you're finding,
please raise them, so we can
try and build better support
for you via the bug tracker.
So a quick TL;DR, users will
expect that to work on all
navigation modes.
Please support it.
Try and create immersive UIs,
because it's giving your apps
more real estate to display in.
Proactively update the
Jetpack and MDC libraries,
because we are going to add
more support as time goes.
And only use the
gesture exclusion API
if you really need them.
They're really meant as an
escape hatch for your apps.
And finally, let us know
about troublesome scenarios
via the issue tracker
we just spoke about.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]